you're from the Bronx yeah I was born
and raised in the South Bronx okay Mets
fan though
what's up Mets fan Mets fan okay yeah
Thank You fan yeah that matter to me I'm
from Boston yeah I hate them all equally
you that means that you didn't drive I
don't think you drove at all and then
you get cast on this show and they say
come to LA we're gonna shoot us a show
how quickly did you have to learn how to
drive did you have to learned that you
have to learn how to drive for the role
yeah for the show so I so I wasn't I
wouldn't be allowed to film if I didn't
have the license and the insurance and
all that for insurance purposes
so I landed I got to the production
office and the guy goes well we're first
scene we're filming is you pulling up in
the car no so when he says gonna teach
me how to drive wait now did they
already asked you at any point if you
could drive maybe perhaps that the first
audition you know no one tells the truth
at those auditions right if they ask you
can you do I surgery you're like yes I
can I've been performing that surgeries
for years right no and so what I've
taken to doing recently I do a lot of
self tapes now not so much going into
audition I lie about my height all the
time now right because if you cast me
then I show up what are you gonna do
yeah that's a great that you show up on
the sub like what are you going to do I
said I was Siri to find another actor in
LA
I'm not budging yeah I'm certainly not
growing yeah yeah 13 reasons why amazing
show I mean this has got to be it's
exciting for you such a massive fan base
2 and hardcore fans really hardcore fans
that's the sign that you guys are doing
something amazing pretty humbling and
we've been able to connect I think the
success of the show is because of the
relatability yeah
these young people all over the world
because it's been released in I think
193 countries they identify with these
characters and it's been the greatest
privilege of my young life and my young
career to be able to say I've helped
these people in anyway yeah so it's a
blessing and I'm very humbled you know
what delightful talking to you you're
very nice guy and very happy for you
very happy for all your success
you